first we have west virginia democrat joe
manchin he is now feeling the wrath
of his own party's woke mob now manchin
recently opposed
sr1 and of course eliminating the
filibuster
now sr1 is the insane election
legislation that would
unconstitutionally
federalize all of our elections and ban
basic voter integrity laws
simple stuff like voter id he also
blocked efforts to abolish the
filibuster
and because of mansions common sense
constitutional opposition
to the radical socialist left's power
grab well as fou
his fellow democrats the media mob they
are now denouncing his moves
as racist remember first rule of the far
left in their politics
if you dare to oppose them in any way
you're a racist
but joe biden he's against oh let's see
integration of schools partners with a
former klansman
praises the former klansmen and
segregationists
and doesn't want our public schools to
become racial jungles
he's okay he gets a pass now you have
congressman
bonder jones accusing manchin of
preserving jim crow so did congresswoman
the real speaker of the house
ocasio-cortez
congresswoman omar suggesting that
manchester was participating
in an effort to dismantle democracy
social justice warrior jameel hill
calling manchin a quote power hungry
white
dude who is upholding white supremacy
maybe this explains the other terror and
fear
of president sippy cup joe and nancy
pelosi and chuckie schumer
to ever on any occasion stand up to the
radical squad
meanwhile over at msdnc one host there
touting his own theory
that senator joe manchin is not very
bright and doesn't understand
math oh you mean doesn't agree with you
take a look
why should federal action be bipartisan
while republican action at a state level
is totally partisan
it makes no sense which means the gop is
waging
asymmetric warfare on our democracy with
manchin's permission and even
encouragement even if democrats could
get manchin's
seven republican pals to vote for s1
it would still not be enough to get past
his own beloved 60-vote filibuster
threshold
maybe as i've said before on this show
mansion's just not very bright
maybe simple math is beyond him maybe he
doesn't understand what's happening at a
state level
that may be the most charitable
explanation
remember with the left in america today
the new green deal socialist there's no
room for freedom of speech freedom of
thought
there's no difference of opinion allowed
no debate allowed
you submit fully and completely to their
will
or they will label you a dumb racist
those are pretty much their rules
and of course their policies we all know
they're doomed to fail
anytime it's been tried it has failed
look at their policies at our border
on the campaign trail joe biden called
president trump's border policies
and border wall races 2019 well biden
encouraged
migrants to come to the border and apply
for asylum
they're listening to joe now now shortly
after entering the white house biden
stopped
all border wall construction he ended
the
stay in mexico policy pretty much you
know catch and release
it's basically just release he stopped
the deportation of
what is now hundreds of thousands of
illegal immigrants
the biden administration has not only
ignored the law of the land
his administration is aiding and
abetting in the law breaking
and then transporting free of charge or
basically your tax dollars
illegal immigrants into states all
across the country
and forcing every state to take on
illegal immigrants
and the financial burden of food and
water
and shelter and health care and
education
and for the past four months the
southern border has experienced a record
level surge including tens and tens of
thousands
of unaccompanied minors they were stored
in the cages that joey built
and of course in the middle of a
pandemic on top of each other
biden then appointed kamala harris as
his special border czar
unfortunately harris has refused to even
visit the border for herself
the situation is dire we hear from
people on the ground every day
our own eyes show us that and by the way
yesterday
she did head south to the country of
guatemala where she's telling migrants
there
don't come we will enforce our laws
which we all know is a lie
take a look i want to be clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
the united states will continue to
enforce our laws
and secure our border one of our
priorities
will discourage illegal
migration and i believe
if you come to our border you will be
turned back
meaningless words and lies remember back
in 2017 it was harris accusing the trump
administration
of targeting migrants now she's telling
them not to come because the
biden administration is enforcing our
immigration laws our border walls
laws that's a lie we're not doing
anything of the sort
instead of fixing the crisis she's
trying to sweep it under the rug
she's in full denial and what she'll try
to do now
along with sippy cup is bribe latin
american countries
with your taxpayer money that likely the
people in these countries will never see
and meanwhile as we speak we got waves
of migrants
they're crossing illegally they're
immediately released
into this country in exchange for a mere
promise to show up at a court date
if that a lot of times they just
released without a court date
and the radical left wants to offer
something of great value that would be
amnesty that rewards people that don't
respect our laws don't respect our
sovereignty
and don't respect our borders um you'd
think that we'd enforce the law if you
don't like the law
he can change it you don't get to pick
and choose what laws you don't like
now this all despite a brand new 9-0
supreme court ruling that illegal
immigration
is that it is in fact illegal and
thousands of
illegal immigrants are ineligible to
apply for permanent residence
joey might want to listen to the supreme
court when you wake up in the morning
but don't expect kamala's fans and the
media mom to ever fact check her
speech or what she's saying or do any
serious reporting at the border
over the weekend members of the press
they were just thrilled to get
kamala cookies above air force two take
a look at your screen
that's right those cookies handed out by
kamala harris
baked to look like kamala harris and on
saturday night during a speech in north
carolina
well president trump he weighed in
perfectly outlined what are the
disastrous
disastrous biden administration policies
and prosecuted the case as good as
anybody take a look
our border is wide open illegal
immigration is
skyrocketing at a level that we've never
seen before and this is over a period of
a few months
drugs are pouring in gas prices are
soaring
our industries are being pillaged by
foreign cyber attacks that's a lack of
respect for our country and for our
leaders and speaking of our leaders
they're bowing down to
china america is being demeaned and
humiliated on the world stage
that's right humiliated on the world
stage our borders wide open
illegal immigration is skyrocketing our
country is less safe and less secure
joe biden and his borders are kamala
harris
uh are absolutely dishonest and clueless
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else